- You specifically told
me not to double dip,
but the power of the Nutella compelled me.
- I've never had Nutella before.
- I'm really excited about this,
I don't know how I made
it this long in my life
without it.
- I don't even know what it is.
I don't even know if it's
like made out of nuts.
- People have said this is like
God's gift to man and women.
- I'm excited to see
what the hype is about.
- Do people just do this?
Like, do people just be
like, "I had a bad day,
"I'm just going to eat Nutella"?
- A hundred calories per
tablespoon, that's insane.
- Alright, I like this consistency, goo.
Oh yeah.
- I like this, it's really really good.
- I don't like the
consistency, it's really thick.
- This is so good.
- That's like a lot of chocolate at once.
- This is great.
I don't like peanut butter,
but this is like peanut butter's
hot sister I wanna date.
- I don't know. It's not horrible.
I don't think it's the
best thing ever though.
- I like it a lot, I'm scared of that now.
- Definitely have this,
like, when a lady comes over,
like, "Hey, I got some Nutella".
- I don't even know
what it is, it's magic.
- And it's good for you too, right?
No, OK, it's not good for you.
- I see what the hype is about.
- So this is Nutella-banana mix.
- I'm kinda grossed out by
this, I'm not gonna lie.
- Drop test. Oh, there we go.
- Mm. Alright, you got me.
- No, I don't like that.
- It's delicious.
- This is pretty much
like Nutella-banana shake.
- The consistency of this
is like a giant booger.
- I might even lick the
bowl too, just because.
- I feel like you can
serve this to somebody,
I feel like you can say,
"Hey, come over, here's like a (beep) bowl
"that I put together for you".
But that's fine, because
then you can just make more
for yourself and eat it in secrecy.
- This is like a "I just can't
right now" kind of sandwich.
- You've throwing your
waistline to the wind.
- Ah, amazing, I was really
hoping I hated this one.
- I can't talk right
now, I just gotta eat.
- I wish you could like
feel this, it's so crispy.
- Yeah, no, that's disgusting.
- This is good lunchroom collateral,
you can like make your way to the top.
- This tastes like if you took the s'more
to like a really creative
chef and he was like,
"No, no, no, I fix it for you."
- You know how many girls you
could make happy with this?
You could have a party and
just make a bunch of these,
if it's just all women
there, they'll love it.
Everyone's like (eating noises).
- That actually beat my expectations
which were already really high.
- I get why people are like
super excited about it.
- I'm glad I lost my virginity today.
- Yeah, this sucks.
- Am I going to go out
and buy like vats of it?
Probably not.
- I am definitely converted.
I'm a Nutellito.
- I feel like I'm in love.
- I don't know if I'm a Nutella convert
because I'm scared of
what my life will become.
It's like the first time I went to Vegas
and I won a little bit
of money, I was like,
"I need to leave."
- It's perfect, they should
call this "poo from baby angels"
because it's just that heavenly.